experts at the good housekeeping
institute beauty lab tested dozens of
sunscreens to help find the right spf
for you their beauty director april
franzino joins us now april good morning
thanks for being here as people are at
the beach a big topic let's start with
the science how did good housekeeping go
through this process and what are the
factors you're considering yes so our
beauty lab that good housekeeping
intensively
tests these products so they tested both
face and body sunscreens on almost 500
people of different skin tones from fair
to super dark to make sure that they
work and that they're appealing to use
because that's super important so they
are evaluated on their scent their
texture how easy they apply how they
look and feel on your skin after they're
applied and of course how well they
protect against sun damage so all those
factors
is there a sunscreen that's better for
one skin tone from another so all of the
winners in our test work for every skin
tone because that's super important to
us there are some that we tested that
didn't work so well and so we really
want to make sure that we're
recommending the ones that are universal
and anybody can grab them and use them
in their everyday life so nikki and i
should we could use the same one
basically yes you definitely can uh so
which sunscreen came out on top so the
number one body sunscreen in our test
was this one from rodan and fields and
this is the essentials face and body
sunscreen so you can use it on both
which is great spf 50 and it applied
easily it absorbed quickly it didn't
leave that white cast on your skin so it
works on all tones um it protected
against the sun which is super important
it also didn't transfer on fabric so
like your bathing suit and whatever you
might be putting on
and our users really just loved it
across the board they said it was more
like a lotion moisturizer than a
sunscreen they also love the ten dollar
hawaiian tropic that was tested right
yep so there's about that one so yeah if
you want a great value at the drugstore
hawaiian tropic antioxidant lotion spf
50 was a great choice too this one
didn't dehydrate skin it didn't irritate
it also had great sun protection and
everybody loved the scent it had that
tropical course
fiji scent and so that's so important
not greasy not greasy
out there cooking no you're not sticky
or tacky so it's really important that
people want to use the sunscreen and
it's it smells nice and it feels nice
because otherwise you're just not going
to use it what about expiration dates
can sunscreen expire mine's been sitting
in my closet for five years oh it
definitely does i've had experiences
with this too so if you open your
sunscreen and it's separated or it
smells bad don't use it um and also you
want to look at the date the fda
requires that brands put an expiration
date on the bottle of the sunscreen and
if you don't see one it's it's actually
tested to be effective for up to three
years but that being said we usually
recommend if it's open don't use it
after a year because it may be not as
effective and you don't want to just be
putting something on and get burned not
knowing that it's not working anymore
what about the kitties so yeah for for
children we really recommend using a
mineral sunscreen formula so these are
made with zinc oxide or titanium dioxide
or both and they're really usually more
mild on skin so you want something very
gentle and neutrogena has a great one um
which is pure and free baby sunscreen
spf 50 our experts in the gydoska beat
institute use this for both their own
sensitive skin and their children and
their babies um super gentle and really
high waterproofing so spf um so the spf
50 and the 80 minute water resistance so
if you can actually get it on your child
yeah always change that's always that's
always there
what about the water resistant
sunscreens how effective are they water
yeah so there's actually no such thing
as a waterproof or sweat proof sunscreen
but sunscreens can either be labeled as
water resistant for 40 minutes or water
resistant for 80 minutes and so that
means if you're on the water or you are
sweating you have to reapply it after
that time period so you can't go the two
hours normally recommend it um but
you'll you'll be covered up to that
point
show us how to apply properly and some
of the tips we need to know yeah so
that's the thing most people don't apply
as much sunscreen as you're supposed to
to get the spf value on the package
supposed to put a healthy amount on yeah
a good amount so we recommend two
tablespoons and this is a recommendation
you know dermatologists use two
tablespoons for your whole body and then
for your face you want to use a nickel
size dollop which is not too bad so you
like roughly want about this much for
your face okay i've been way off on my
ass isn't it like a shot glass amount
for you yeah same as a shot glass just
about a reason to take a shot i'm just
taking it and squeezing my hands and i'm
just lathering my whole
um but generally you want to if you have
you're out for a whole beach day you
might almost use a whole bottle of
sunscreen oh well we appreciate you
april franzino thank you so much thank
you